[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
buscarlo en google cuál es la ciudad más
cara del planeta
seguramente estaréis pensando en nueva
york hong kong o tal vez zúrich en suiza
pues nada de eso la ciudad más cara del
mundo es luanda y es la capital de
angola en áfrica
os hagáis una idea si queréis alquilar
un apartamento en luanda podéis llegar a
pagar la friolera de cinco mil dólares
al mes el precio de un menú bigmac 19
dólares y si queréis tener internet en
casa ya podéis ir preparando la cartera
porque os costará unos 300 dólares al
mes
y os preguntaréis qué está pasando en
angola se trata de un país millonario en
mitad de áfrica pues nada de eso por
supuesto que la república de angola es
uno de los principales exportadores de
petróleo del mundo superan a países como
qatar por ejemplo sin embargo la mitad
de su población ni siquiera tiene acceso
a agua potable dos de cada tres niños
angoleños sufren de malnutrición y uno
de cada seis muere antes de cumplir los
cinco años
mientras tanto angola es el hogar de una
de las mujeres más ricas del mundo
isabel dos santos que por cierto también
es la hija del presidente del país josé
eduardo dos santos
a estas alturas ya os habréis dado
cuenta de lo que pasa aquí angola es uno
de los países más corruptos del mundo y
también uno de los fiascos financieros
más colosales de los últimos años muchas
empresas han perdido auténticas fortunas
en este país
[Música]
en fin supongo que no estaréis
sorprendidos a fin de cuentas angola no
deja de ser un país del tercer mundo
verdad sin embargo hay una pregunta cómo
han llegado hasta aquí cómo es posible
que un país llegue a una situación
semejante y lo que es más importante
cómo es posible que el partido político
que gobierna angola continúe ganando
elecciones con porcentajes que superan
el 70 por ciento hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
diamantes sangre y diplomacia lo primero
que tenemos que entender cuando hablamos
de áfrica es que casi todos los países
de la zona estuvieron colonizados
durante siglos por países europeos
[Música]
bélgica francia o portugal invadieron
casi todo el continente imponiendo
gobiernos despóticos y tratando a los
ciudadanos nativos como si fuera un poco
más que ganado angola no se quedó atrás
hasta el año 1975 portugal ganó
muchísimo dinero exportando los
diamantes que había en el país sin
embargo en ese año 1975 el gobierno
portugués reconoció la independencia de
angola después de recibir toda clase de
presiones tanto por parte de la onu como
de los propios portugueses pero la
pregunta es qué pasa después de que un
país se descolonice quien se hace cargo
del gobierno después de que se vayan los
colonos europeos
pues bien en lugar de responder a esta
pregunta celebrando unas elecciones las
distintas tribus de angola formaron
facciones y se enfrentaron en una guerra
civil
[Música]
hablamos de un conflicto que se prolongó
por más de 25 años para que os hagáis
una idea todavía hoy hay zonas en el
país donde no se puede caminar porque
están cubiertas de minas antipersonas
por si alguien no sabe lo que son las
minas antipersona se trata de unas
bombas que se esconden debajo de la
tierra y que explotan cuando alguien las
pisa y os preguntaréis cómo es posible
que un país tan pobre pudiera pagar todo
ese armamento pues bien la respuesta
está en los diamantes los distintos
mandos de la guerra angoleña vendían
estos diamantes a cambio de armas
[Música]
pero quien se la suministraba pues bien
a partir del año 1976 que es cuando
podemos hablar de una guerra civil en
toda regla teníamos dos bandos en este
país
por un lado estaba el llamado un ita que
dominaba el sur del país aún y está lo
apoyaba en sudáfrica china y en menor
medida eeuu no olvidéis que estábamos en
la guerra fría cualquier conflicto era
una oportunidad para ganar influencia y
debilitar al enemigo y además ya se
sabía que angola tenía grandes
cantidades de petróleo por explotar y
por eso mismo la unión soviética tampoco
se quedó atrás y decidió apoyar al
movimiento popular de liberación
angoleña liderado por el actual
presidente eduardo dos santos
por supuesto los santos contaba con el
apoyo de la unión soviética pero sin
duda alguna el país que más se volcó en
influir en la política de angola fue
cuba
amos cumpliendo un elemental deber
internacionalista cuando ayudamos al
pueblo de angola
fidel castro no sólo vendió armas a dos
santos sino que también envió más de
30.000 tropas al país pero no sólo eso
durante los años 80 la zona que
controlaba este movimiento de liberación
popular de angola recibió ingenieros y
médicos de cuba y eso explica en parte
porque los santos terminó ganando este
conflicto
hecho en los años 90 aunque la guerra
todavía no había terminado este hombre
controlaba prácticamente todo el país
[Música]
sin embargo estas ayudas cubanas no
fueron tan útiles como os podríais
pensar por ejemplo los ingenieros
agrónomos de la habana intentaron
cultivar caña de azúcar en las tierras
angoleñas pero al parecer este tipo de
cultivos intensivos no debían de ser lo
más indicado para el tipo de terreno que
hay en el país así que en pocos años las
tierras de cultivo de angola quedaron
completamente inútiles para la
agricultura eso significaba más
hambrunas para los angoleños que
empezaban a estar un poco hartos de esa
ayuda cubana
pero por si esto fuera poco tras el
colapso de la unión soviética
eduardo dos santos se da cuenta de que
es mejor llevarse bien con los países
capitalistas a fin de cuentas son los
que pueden comprar el petróleo por otra
parte eeuu llevaba años sin enviar
ningún tipo de apoyo a los guerrilleros
de unita así que quien más necesitaba
para poderse llevar bien con el llamado
mundo libre es muy sencillo basta con
quitar la palabra marxista de tu
vocabulario y sustituirla por el término
democracia liberal y si le pongo todas
las comillas del mundo porque el
capitalismo angoleño es un sistema
aparte
democracia a la angoleña el año 2002 es
un punto clave en la historia de angola
eduardo dos santos firma la paz con sus
adversarios desde entonces unita se
convierte en un partido político más con
derecho a presentarse a las elecciones y
por primera vez en la historia los
angoleños descubren lo bonita que es la
democracia pero no sólo eso en este
mismo año ocurre otra cosa también muy
importante x petroleum descubre petróleo
en aguas profundas en la costa de angola
de repente angola se convierte en un
gigante del petróleo que suministra
toneladas de zumo de dinosaurio a países
como china o eeuu en sólo 5 años
angola multiplica su riqueza por 4 tan
con las capturas para capital de angola
ha sido reconstruida la arquitectura de
los años 50 y 60 y da paso a nuevas
torres de oficinas construidas por el
sector empresarial y nacional y el
gobierno empresas como exxon mobile en
eeuu
en reinounido comienzan a invertir en
angola y por supuesto envían a
ingenieros y trabajadores para que vivan
en la capital luanda
y la gente quiere vivir en viviendas de
calidad salir por bares y comprar
productos como los que comprarían sus
países de origen pero todo esto es
prácticamente imposible de encontrar en
un país que tan solo unos años atrás
estaba en plena guerra civil en otras
palabras la oferta era escasa y la
demanda no dejaba de subir como
resultado los precios de los bienes
vamos a decir occidentales subieron como
la espuma de five andry construida para
albergar a 500 mil personas la capital
de angola alberga ahora mismo alrededor
de 5 millones incluso los funcionarios
con buenos salarios tienen problemas
para llegar a fin de mes pero esperad un
momento porque hay mucho más imaginad
que tenemos una empresa constructora en
china y queremos levantar un edificio de
viviendas en luanda pues bien lo primero
que tendríamos que hacer es registrar
una empresa en angola bien este proceso
puede llegar a durar más de seis meses y
durante este tiempo es perfectamente
normal que el gobierno encuentre montt
dones de problemas legales
que si necesito este papel que si tienes
que rellenar este registro en definitiva
la clase de problemas que solo pueden
solucionarse deslizando un pago de
billetes según varios informes de
transparencia internacional
prácticamente todas las empresas que han
hecho negocios en angola han tenido que
pagar algún tipo de soborno al gobierno
pero esperad porque la cosa no termina
aquí todas estas grandes petroleras como
exxon móbil o british petroleum que
querían explotar el petróleo angoleño
tenían que asociarse o bien con el
gobierno o bien con la petrolera estatal
de angola se trata de una gran
corporación que se llama zona goal
ya que no adivináis quien es la actual
presidenta de esta empresa efectivamente
isabel dos santos la hija de eduardo dos
santos quien fue presidente de angola
durante casi 40 años cosas como esta
explican por qué isabel dos santos ha
llegado a ser la mujer más rica de
áfrica en muy pocos años
todas las grandes inversiones de dos
santos en angola provienen o bien de
quedarse con una parte del negocio de
una empresa extranjera en el país o bien
de convencer al presidente para que les
dé permiso para hacer negocios todo esto
mientras el gobierno de dos santos padre
restringía el acceso a casi todos los
periodistas internacionales que querían
contar lo que ocurre en el país de hecho
casi todos los casos de corrupción que
se conocen en angola han aparecido
gracias a las investigaciones del
gobierno de reino unido o de eeuu
[Música]
por supuesto con este clima político
ningún angoleño ha podido montar ninguna
empresa a fin de cuentas hace falta ser
millonario para poder pagar todos esos
sobornos que exigía el gobierno para que
os hagáis una idea dejando a un lado
todo el coste de la corrupción sólo con
los gastos en trámites burocráticos
necesitaríamos gastarnos más de mil
dólares para poder montar un bar en
luanda y en un país tan pobre como
angola esos mil dólares son un auténtico
lujo
[Música]
pero no sólo eso esas empresas
internacionales tampoco estaban
dispuestas a invertir más allá de lo
justo y necesario para poder extraer el
petróleo y todo esto qué consecuencias
ha tenido para el país pues básicamente
que angola sólo produce petróleo los
últimos negocios que se han hecho en
angola han sido plantas de extracción y
casas para la gente que trabaja en las
petroleras en el año 2014
el petróleo suponía el 97 por ciento de
las exportaciones de este país
[Música]
zona de algo esta historia si lleváis
tiempo suscritos a visual político
seguro que estaréis pensando en un país
que tenía una economía muy parecida
exacto hablamos de venezuela al igual
que en el país de nicolás maduro en el
momento en el que el precio del barril
de petróleo cayó en el mercado
internacional
angola se fue al traste
y ahora volvemos al ejemplo de la
constructora china porque muchas
empresas de este país invirtieron
millones de dólares en construir barrios
enteros para todos esos profesionales
que venían a trabajar en el sector
petrolero de angola pero como ya no hay
sector petrolero
tampoco hay trabajadores full en hub es
vital que las autopistas sin coches
escuelas sin estudiantes durante cinco
años una empresa china construyó callum
va usando líneas de crédito pagadas
entre china y el petróleo de angola pero
parte de callum va parece hoy una ciudad
fantasma en definitiva que sólo hay un
beneficiado en toda esta historia y esa
persona es jose eduardo dos santos y su
hija isabel que ya se han encargado de
hacer una fortuna y de invertir la en
empresas de todo el mundo casi todas las
grandes empresas portuguesas desde golf
hasta unitel están controladas por esta
familia si portugal fue la potencia
colonizadora de angola hoy en día se ha
convertido en su lavadora de dinero se
estima que las élites angoleñas
unos 190.000 millones de dólares fuera
del país en los últimos 10 años
y mientras el país está en crisis isabel
dos santos que en su cuenta de 'twitter'
se autodenomina emprendedora' seco día
con famosos como kim kardashian con este
panorama os podéis imaginar que la
popularidad de la familia de los santos
no es demasiado alta verdad
sin embargo su partido político este
movimiento popular de liberación
angoleña continúa arrasando en las
elecciones con porcentajes de voto que
superan el 70 por ciento sin ir más
lejos este mes de agosto han tenido
nuevos comicios y han vuelto a ganar con
resultados estúpidamente altos y os
preguntaréis cómo se puede explicar esto
pues me temo que nunca lo llegaremos a
saber
angola rechaza tener observadores de la
unión europea en sus elecciones y ahora
la pregunta es podrá algún día angola
deshacerse de esa élite corrupta que les
gobierna pueden seguir el camino de
otros leones africanos como ghana o
ruanda podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios mientras tanto si
queréis saber lo que está ocurriendo en
el país vecino en sudáfrica hacer clic
en este otro vídeo y como siempre si
queréis estar al tanto de lo que ocurre
en el mundo incluido áfrica en visual
político publicamos vídeos todas las
semanas así que suscribe os al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo
dante a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]